نعم انا الان داخل احدى الصيدليات التي
تعتبر من الصيدليات الكبيره في هذا الشارع
هنا في ام درمان ارصد لكم اخر التطورات
على مستوى الصيدليات وعلى مستوى الامداد
الدوائي داخل هذه الصيدليه
نعم مركز الرومي كان هنالك اشتباكات
والمواط الاولى وكما كانوا داخل هذا
المركز شاهدوا وجوه وقوعه قذيفه داخل هذا
المركز واصيب اكثر من عشره اصابات نقلوا
الى مستشفى النوم وهو مستشفى معروف هنا في
منطقه
الان العربيه داخل هذه
الصيدليه وكما تشاهدون هنالك توافق كبير
ونسبي وبصوره يوميه على هذه الصيدليه بعد
ان اغلقت جميع المراكز الصحيه قرب هذه
المنطقه ابوابها نسبه لخطوره الوضع الامني
الذي يقول
ان تقول المراكز الصحيه ان الوضع الامني
اصبح يعني
يشكل هاجزا بالنسبه الطبيه وبالنسبه كذلك
للامداد الامداد الدوائي انا الان يمكن ان
اجري اذا كان هنالك وقت يعني مقابله مع
دكتور الدكتور مصعب وهو
وهو المسؤول من هذه الصيدليه الدكتور مصعب
ممكن ان تنضم الى قناه العربيه لتحدثنا عن
الوضع الصحي
وكميه المرضى الذين يصلون هذه هذه
الصيدليه يوميا هل تلاحظ اي تغيير في عدد
المرضى بعد نشوب الاشتباكات بين قوات الد
عم السوداني
[موسيقى]
نتيجه لعدد توفر الانف
هل انت شغال بصوره يوميه ولا بتشتغل ساعات
معينه في اليوم
هذه صوره يوميه
لتوفير الدوائر
للمواطنين بصوره يوميه بصوره يوميه ان شاء
الله
طيب بالنسبه
لعدد المرضى يوميا يعني يعني في عدد جزئين
في تزايد في عدد المرضى هل لاحظت اي
الادويه طيب عندك الادويه يا مهمه قطعت او
هي شارفت على الانتهاء والمخزون الدوائر
ضعيف جدا في هذه
بالنسبه لتوافق الشركات
هل في اي شركات باشرت العمل في الفتره
السابقه يعني حسب علمي لا طيب المخزون
اللي عندكم بكفيكم كملا الى الزمن يعني
على حسب تصورك
هل في ادويه مهمه ادويه للسكر يعني تطلع
من الادويه للحياه بصوره خاصه
طيب بالنسبه لانه الغرفه مصنعي الادويه
كانت او اعلنت في بيان قبل قليل انه هنالك
نهب كبير لمصانع الادويه بمنطقه البحري
وسوبا والباقيه ما رؤيه او ما رايك في في
حدوث مثل هكذا مشاكل يعني بالنسبه لل
قطاع الامريكي
قاعد تقدم الاستشارات طبيه هنا بدلا على
الاطباء داخل الصيدليه
اصلا الحمد لله
والخبره الاذان ان شاء الله
اللي هو فين مع المواطنين ان شاء الله
ربنا يقدرنا ان شاء الله نقدم المواطنين
نستطيع نعم كما تلاحظون الان ان هنالك
توافد لعدد
مقدر من المرضى داخل هذه الصيدليه
وان الطبيب والدكتور مصعب هو من يقدم
الاستشارات وان هنالك خطوره على الوضع
الامني في هذه المنطقه وفي الامداد
الدوائي بعدما نشرت غرفه مصنعين الالوف
الادويه بيان لها تقول ان هنالك عدد كبير
من مصانع الادويه
قد تعرضت بصوره كبيره منذ اندلاع الايام
الاولى
للاشتباكات بين القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع وكذلك ان انها قالت ايضا
حذرت للقطاع هذه الادويه الادويه المنقده
للحياه اذا ما استمر الحال واذا ما استمر
هذا الحال لايام اخرى وهذا ينذر بخطوره
كبيره في الوضع الصحي في البلاد والجديد
بالذكر كذلك ان الامم المتحده كانت قد
اعلنت عنها ان اكثر من 420 اصابه
منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات واكثر من ثلاثه
انفس ثلاثه الاف وسبعمئه
قتيلا واكثر من 3,7
الاصابه في البلاد منذ اندلاع على
الاشتباكات بين الدعم السريع الجيش
واصابات بالالاف مقداد طالما نتحدث في هذا
الاطار نبقى دائما
الادويه وكذلك اعوذ بك لو سمحت الى ما كنت
اوردته في نشرات سابقه عن استهداف مركز
الرومي الطبي حدثنا اكثر عن هذه المنطقه
بمعنى مع استهداف هذا المركز
هل هناك مراكز اخرى متوفره ما الذي يعني
كيف سيضر ذلك
بالسير العادي من يتوجه لمحاوله ايجاد
وسائل للتطبيب هل سيجد معاناه حقيقيه ام
ان هناك مراكز اخرى قد تفهم الحاجه حدثنا
اكثر عن هذه التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
نعم من بالواقع الحال وبطبيعه الحال ان
الاطباء الصيادله هم اللي يقومون
بالاستشارات في الحالات البارده كما
اجرينا قبل قليل مع مع دكتور مصعب
والكثير من الحالات تلجا الى الصيدليات
او اما بالنسبه للحالات التي تحتاج الى
جراحه وتحتاج الى الى الى اسعاف طبي هنالك
كثير من المبادرات قامت في هذا الجانب
ودعت اليها كثير من المنظمات
والمنظمات العالميه الوضع الصحي في هذه
المنطقه بعد بعد ان
تمت وقوع قذيفه في مركز الرومي وهو من
المراكز التي تقدم في النص صحيه كبيره
بالنسبه للحالات البارده واستشارات في
مختلف التخصصات الطبيه في القلب
والضغط والسكري وكذلك الموجات الصوتيه
والاشعه هذا هذا قد يؤدي الى الى الى الى
الى الى الى الى الى زياده في حجم الكارثه
الصحيه
حتى افهم منك فقط هذه القذيفه التي سقطت
على اثر الاشتباكات بين الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني اثرت به بمعنى انها اوقفت
خدمه هذا المركز تماما
نعم هو هو خانق اعلن انه عود الى العمل
بالامس القريب ثم بعد حدوث هذه
الاشتباكات بين قوه الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني وقعد على اثرها داخل هذا المركز
بعدها بساعات اعلن المركز انه لا يستطيع
ان يقدم الخدمات الصحيه نسبه للخطوره
الوضع الامني ونسبه
كذلك حفاظا على الكادر الطبي الذي هو ايضا
يعاني كثيرا الى الوصول الى المرافق
الصحيه هنالك مستشفى قليل في منطقه الثوره
ما زال الى
الان يضحية كبير وهو مستشفى حكومي ولكن
هنالك عدد كبير جدا وهنالك يعني
عدد كبير جدا من الاصابات ومن الذين
يحتاجون الى هذا المركز مما يعني ان هنالك
ضغط على الكاميرا الطبي في مركز النوبه
وضحت الفكره وشكرك جزيلا الش
كر على اصيل كذلك من امانه الصحفي مقداد
حسن شكرا لك